dans la cour d'école les enfants vous
crient Orléans assassins
heureux de vous avoir sur le plateau de
Tout le monde en parle
bah si a pas été trop désagréable tout à
l'heure non personne n'est désagréable
merci que vous
tu dis voilà c'est bien de laisser une
place entre vous deux
[Rires]
bien alors John de France princesse
d'Orléans duchesse de Wurtenberg
Stéphane Bern vous consacre un ouvrage
publié chez Flammarion et qui s'intitule
Diane de France la princesse rebelle
voilà donc nous avons avec nous avons
avec nous une rebelle
pas la babouche bien vous êtes né le
dimanche de Pâques 1940 au Brésil car
votre père le conte de Paris devant la
montée de la guerre devant la montée des
périls avait envoyé toute la famille au
Brésil pour la mettre à l'abri voilà et
vous êtes né à Petropolis exactement à
quelques quoi sans bandes de Rio de
Janeiro c'est ça
aujourd'hui c'est dans la montagne c'est
un peu le Versailles brésilien
les empereurs du Brésil voilà alors
votre mère était là donc déjà quand vous
arrivez et parce que votre mère
c'est l'habitude c'est la merde
ux
on en a eu des culs de portée mais elle
était
trop police dans le Versailles brésilien
j'espère que mes amis téléspectateurs
qui regardent cette émission pour se
cultiver suivre ce que je dis il regarde
sur la carte où est Métropolis
absolument alors quand la guerre
commence votre père s'engage incognito
dans la Légion étrangère sous le nom de
Aurillac mais il est démobilisé
évidemment en 40 quand il y a
l'armistice il s'installe au Maroc où il
devient l'héritier du trône de France à
la mort de son propre père c'est comme
ça que ça se passe voilà alors à
l'époque la loi d'exil interdit aux
familles ayant régné sur la France de
vivre en France donc vous êtes en exil
au Maroc vous êtes élevé comme une
espèce de petite sauvage jaune on
pourrait dire
je crois que c'était dans moi-même
sauvageonne parce que mais c'est
l'éducation n'a pas été sauvageonne du
tout on a une éducation très stricte ce
qui est très bien pour plus tard mais je
crois que c'est mon caractère qui
sortait de là et j'étais intitulée par
tout ceux de la famille la sauvage le
vilain petit canard
[Rires]
calme-toi voilà donc vous vivez au Maroc
cette prime en France ensuite l'Espagne
à Pampelune et le Portugal dans le dans
la maison de votre père La Cuenta voilà
il a
là vous entrez en rébellion contre
pratiquement la terre entière et vous
dites très jeune personne ne décidera à
ma place la couleur de mes pulls
à une psy qui était venu me voir je dis
personne ne désirera à partir
d'aujourd'hui ce que je vais faire de ma
vie et moi je décide moi-même ce que je
veux faire et c'est ça qui m'a c'est que
la psy était pas très contente
tellement diane était rebelle après le
passage chez la psy effectivement on l'a
mis dans une institution pour handicapé
mentaux oui bah oui parce que si tu veux
là à cette époque là ça rigolait pas une
seconde
fréquenté aussi moi ça a été ma chance
et là vous étiez avec des enfants qui
étaient de tout incapables de
reconnaître une pomme d'un chat
j'avais beaucoup de peine pour
moi je prenais les coups de bâton pour
parce que j'avais trop de peine mais
comme petite fille de 9 ans qui prend
des coups de bâton pour les autres ça
dure une deux semaines et après j'ai dit
moi je veux plus continuer à te prendre
des coups de bâton mais ça me faisait de
la peine alors à l'issue de ce séjour
dans cette institution pour pour
handicaper mentaux hein vous rompez
carrément avec votre famille vous vous
ne voulez plus les voir non je vois mais
ça m'était complètement égal vous
comprenez
étant donné qu'on est on a un timbre sur
nous on nous décrète imbécile idiot moi
je dis pas c'est très bien à partir
d'aujourd'hui moi je vais encore plus
que à partir de là vous êtes élevé et
vous êtes élevé par les domestiques à
partir
adorable venez du Limousin je lui
chantais la Madelon alors c'était pas
très correct non plus elle disait
princesse Diane n'en fait pas ça elle
m'a éduqué elle est adorable et je
j'allais avec les ouvriers dans
l'affaire au fond je fichais rien vous
êtes élevé par des domestiques et en
1950 l'Assemblée nationale approche la
loi d'exil vous rentrez en France je
finis par rentrer et là quand vous allez
dans une école française vous êtes
victime alors là du passé historique de
votre famille dans la cour d'école les
enfants vous crient Orléans assassin
moi j'étais furieuse parce que je dis
comment ce qu'ils peuvent
oser dire que mon père est un assassin
enfin on l'a porté tout ce qui s'est
passé des rois de France mais je trouve
que c'était injuste j'ai vu un panneau
énorme Orléans 80 km je n'y ai pas cru
casser plus court
quand même c'est quand même des
dénonciations tout le temps
l'ancêtre de Diane Philippe Égalité a
voté la mort de son cousin Louis XVI je
sais pas si toi tu voterais la mort de
ton cousin oui non
non
voilà non voilà et ensuite
Louis-Philippe a chassé Charles X son
cousin deux fois de suite
à l'école vous tombiez sur des enfants
c'est vrai mais vous n'avez pas besoin
d'attaquer le nom de mon père moi je
suis défendais quand même mon père mais
vous comprenez quand même que que des
enfants et puis vous dire ça à l'époque
c'est les parents qui leur ont dit ça
c'est pas eux les parents qui étaient
partisans
c'est un espèce de stupidité de racisme
contre les en l'air en tous les cas vous
êtes fait insulter à l'école qu'est-ce
que vous faites le 19 ans vous épousez
une burtenberg votre frère Henri qui est
donc maintenant l'héritier du trône a
dit que c'était des mariages à ranger
tout ça non c'est absolument pas vrai
lui il était fou amoureux de Alyssa je
peux vous le dire parce que quand on a
l'air en chemin il fallait toujours
s'arrêter pour téléphoner à cette époque
il y avait pas les mobiles qui s'appelle
Marie-Thérèse alors il téléphone et moi
j'ai jamais arrête de téléphoner fiche
nous la paye emmène-nous là où on veut
aller donc en fait c'est pas vrai mais
non votre mariage n'a pas été arrangé
pour réconcilier parce que vous savez
bien quand même que ça a aidé à la
réconciliation franco-allemande ça fait
du un boomer
que des
aristocrates français épouser des
aristocrates allemands c'était bien
ah oui c'était très bien pour la
politique
vous seriez prête à vous appuyer en
Elton John quoi
[Applaudissements]
6 enfants
alors le problème quand même faut le
dire c'est que la vie chez levure
tenberg c'était pas très très drôle
c'est pas facile à prononcer déjà
c'était pas vrai mais avec mon humour
moi je riais oui
vous arrivez à Zurich il a même pas
réservé une chambre d'hôtel le mec
franchement on a fait tout oublier vous
êtes obligés de dormir dans un bouge oui
oui camping
j'ai retrouvé toute la famille à
l'aéroport ça a été de nouveau des
embrassants
ma vie il y a eu des choses ce livre
montre que c'est une femme qui a passé
par des hauts et des bactéries mais à
chaque fois grâce à son humour elle s'en
sort et elle rigole de la plus
importante des bêtises qu'on me faisait
et des mauvaises choses
après ça c'est bien passé ça ça vous
regarde c'est une bonne mentalité
on faisait
comme dans le Titanic
bien alors après il y a un épisode un
petit peu tragique sérieusement c'est le
voyage de noces donc vous êtes à Rio
vous rencontrez une diseuse de
Bonaventure qui vous qui vous tire qui
vous tient les cartes et qui vous
annoncent la mort de votre frère
François qui est mort en héros en
Algérie on s'en souvient tous et c'est
un petit peu le début du déclin de la
famille d'Orléans on peut le dire quoi
la mort de Françoise
un grand choc pour papa et maman nous
tous aussi moi aussi c'était mon héros
comme je dis dans le livre et là vous
découvrez un petit peu quand même
votre père quoi ça vous êtes très déçu
par votre père par exemple il avait
promis une date pour vous il l'a pas
payé quoi c'est dur ça on a beau avoir
de l'humour
la situation de ma belle-famille envers
moi avec Norman mon père me dit oh mais
c'est très bien très bien ça donnerait
une tente et puis je n'ai jamais vu la
couleur bon
qui avait été promis par votre père il
avait dit je te donnerai une date
c'était mal interprété et le non ce qui
s'est passé
de s'appuyer les frais du mariage et
Henri votre père n'a rien donné voilà
donc vous quand vous étiez face à cette
famille des vertèbres c'était très
compliqué pour vous les objectifs
c'était gênant parce qu'on était un peu
comme un coucou qui viendra
c'est un peu embêtant d'ailleurs il vous
mène la vie dure c'est Würtenberg c'est
pas facile pour vous vous avez des
problèmes
c'est un petit peu la boulette mais je
crois comme vous en parlez comme vous en
avez tellement tellement d'endettement
je crois que vous en parlez dans le
livre donc on peut en parler c'est un
petit peu
avec personne non simplement alors
Laurent tu sois que tu sois Laurent que
tu sois au courant
Diane par seul en Espagne
en Espagne
c'est congés payés alors voilà la phrase
j'ai trouvé le réconfort sur l'épaule
compatissante d'homme
futile roi prince ou simple anonyme
non on n'est pas content non on est
passé
tout à fait normal
partirait en congés payés comme vous
dites avec des rois des princes voir de
ça
pas pour toujours
et voilà qu'on se parle
non honnêtement vous avez eu de la
chance permettez-moi de vous le dire
j'ai de la chance de tomber sur un homme
Karl qui a une certaine grandeur
[Musique]
un grand seigneur
peut-être qu'un jour vous l'aurez ici
mais j'espère mais c'est dommage qu'il
soit pas venus
sans problème en combien de temps
je vois pas pourquoi faire du blablabla
j'ai dit écoute voilà je reviens et bien
tout le monde
je suis là tout le monde tout le monde
du château les enfants tout le monde
n'ont qu'une envie que je revienne parce
que il faut voir que quand je suis parti
les dames doivent le savoir quand on
quitte la maison c'est le bordel après
dans la maison
moi ils ont bien vu que finalement je
faisais quelque chose donc on va revenir
finalement alors ils étaient tous
contents
est-ce que vous êtes reparti ensuite en
congés payés
une fois mais après vous avez plus
jamais fait d'écart Diane bon d'accord
ok c'est bon ok c'est bon pas mal de
toute façon elle était avec des épaules
c'était pas des épaules oui tu as raison
on peut dire que c'est pas grave une
épaule alors une épaule pour combien de
personnes par exemple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais moi je vais leur dire comment faire
des choses mais je veux pas passer on
est à la cuisine
mais touche pas
je vois pas pourquoi je crois qu'il y a
des gens pour le faire
manger
tous les deux je vais aller manger on va
manger après
sur l'épaule
les congés
québécoises là-bas c'est très encore ils
sont sucré
alors donc on irait là vous savez où on
en est oui donc Carl pardonne
excuse-moi les sandwichs que vous avez
amené dans la chambre et sur la géniaux
bravo le voir
c'est bien
tu l'as dit dans la chambre non quoi
dans la loge dans la loge je crois que
c'est une chambre alors
allons-y donc alors là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là commence les querelles entre vos
parents et quenelles
[Rires]
pour te donner un exemple pour donner un
exemple de quel âge
[Rires]
le poulet je vais le faire
pardon ça s'appelle poulet sodomie
alors non je vais vous dire un truc
c'est pas des trucs de cochons c'est un
truc de poulet tu mets une bouteille de
bière vide tu mets de l'eau dedans tu
mets ça dans le truc du poulet ça
s'appelle ce demi tu sais où tu le mets
quoi
tu poses le poulet dessus tu mets le
poulet dans le four et l'eau sort de la
bouteille comme vapeur et un Bible imbib
non il y a plus de bière la bouteille
elle est vide de bière une bouteille de
ce que tu veux une bouteille en verre et
l'eau imbib toute la chair du poulet
c'est extraordinaire je te rappelle que
le poulet mineur
et Satan sur le coup de la loi c'est un
poulet de 23 jours
je suis pas sûr qu'on puisse faire ça
avec un poulet de 23 jours
[Applaudissements]
c'est un nouveau truc dans l'émission
régulièrement je fais des bisous pour se
rassurer
[Applaudissements]
ces moments c'est des moments revenir à
l'essentiel alors là commence les
querelles
là commence les querelles donc entre vos
parents alors pour donner un exemple des
querelles entre les parents de Diane
entre le compte de Paris et sa femme
quand votre père a un accident cardiaque
votre mère dit PAF tu nous gâcheras
toujours nos vacances sympa
une pièce mortuaire au cas où il meurt
mais sérieux c'est incroyable moi
j'étais la première à courir près de
papa parce que il m'a demandé que je
vienne jusqu'au moment Laurent et là on
est en terrain de connaissance parce
qu'on a déjà beaucoup parlé dans ses
missions avec deux de vos frères donc
vous voyez déjà votre père se fait
mettre le grappin dessus par Madame
frise donc Monique et vous dites dans
votre livre tu sais c'est l'infirmière
avec qui vivait à Chantilly le papa de
Diane le comte de Paris donc il vivait
avec cette infirmière il écoutait la
valise RTL pendant qu'elle passait la
serpillière enfin on déjà beaucoup parlé
de la scène et vous vous avez une phrase
qui est un petit peu terrible pour
Madame frise qui est
une infirmière qui soulageait les
messieurs fortunés et pas seulement de
leur douleur
c'est tout à fait vrai
[Rires]
enfin voilà alors ce qu'il faut dire
maintenant pour régler l'affaire voilà
c'est vrai qu'il y a 50 ans la fortune
des Orléans il y a 50 ans quand ils sont
revenus d'exils ils sont installés à
Louveciennes la fortune des Orléans
était de 1 milliard de nouveaux francs
tu imagines à l'époque il y a 50 ans
1000 milliards de centimes il y avait
des il y avait des forêts et les faux
aujourd'hui les forêts en ont massif
et aujourd'hui donc on peut dire que la
fortune des Orléans est à peu près 70
millions de francs alors moi de toute
manière ça m'intéresse pas j'ai mon mari
qui s'occupe de moi et moi je m'occupe
pas
mais j'ai pas besoin
exceptionnelle en Allemagne on a
beaucoup brodé dessus bon Marie
travaille comme un dingue pour essayer
de maintenir ça bon et là donc vous vous
êtes évadé un petit peu de cet univers à
travers la peinture et la sculpture il
faut pas oublier aussi que j'ai été
gravement malade ça c'est ce livre aussi
important pour beaucoup de discrets
là-dessus pour beaucoup de personnes qui
souffrent peut-être maintenant et qui en
sont peut-être dans les hôpitaux et qui
sont à deux doigts de la mort comme moi
je l'ai été et je crois que ça ça c'est
une souffrance que je ne souhaite à
personne et je vous souhaite à personne
de passer dans tous ces moments où j'ai
su que j'allais mourir à 27 ans on vous
annonce vous n'avez plus que deux ans de
vie c'est comme si on vous lançait dans
un avion avec un parachute et que vous
n'avez pas de parachute vous tombez en
chute libre et vous vous demandez où
est-ce que je tombe où est-ce que je
tombe puis tout d'un coup
c'est une force de volonté de dire je
reprends tout en main et je remonte les
marches
tout à l'heure au sujet de Sophie
démarrer c'est quand on a frôlé la mort
on apprécie plus la vie oui on aime la
vie ça vous fait quoi Diane de France de
voir qu'aujourd'hui les châteaux servent
à tourner la Star Academy ou des films
de cul
c'est une époque qui est évolue et qui
finit vous en prenez votre parti quoi et
ça vous fait quoi de devoir que
Stéphanie de Monaco épouse un acrobate
portugais par exemple c'est son problème
vous êtes choqué parce que vous vous
avez posé un burtenberg quand même oui
maintenant le gouvernement portugais a
démenti c'est pour te dire à quel point
c'est grave gouvernement portugais oui
c'est bon c'est quoi par exemple de voir
que Jérôme le roi est obligé de jouer à
Guingamp
er
et que le futur roi d'Italie épouse une
roturière ça vous fait quoi
quand même et les princes de luxe pas
toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bien alors le bouquin s'appelle Diane de
France princesse rebelle et on va voir
si vous êtes une vraie rebelle interview
rebelle
interview rebelle Laurent Diane de
France est-ce que vous avez déjà dit des
gros mots
vous avez déjà dit des gros mots
est-ce que vous avez déjà porté un jean
voir si vous êtes rebelle oui est-ce que
vous avez déjà fêter le 14 juillet
pas souvent c'est arrivé
est-ce que vous êtes déjà fait pire
c'est le nombril
des années je te dis ça des années bravo
Diane est-ce que est-ce que vous avez
déjà fait l'amour sans désir de procréer
non maintenant six enfants il a fait
l'amour six fois je crois que le compte
est bon les lettres
est-ce que vous avez déjà mis des coups
sur la table et là là là
est-ce que vous avez déjà embrassé une
personne de votre sexe
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu